aiuto aiuto aiuto aiuto aiuto aiuto
aiuto aiuto aiuto aiuto dobbiamo passare
qui a cercare di prendere
questa frittata
Siamo due ore in prigione siamo in una
nuova fresata dovremmo evadere da questa
nuovissima Escape Room nuovo Gameplay Mi
raccomando Mettetevi comodi lasciate un
mi piace proprio scappare da Guardate ma
cioè c'ho un mocciolo che gli scende giù
dal naso verde pure nuova guardia
Aspetta
vediamo come sarà Pronti Via Eccoci qua
Beh siamo nella nostra cella Ok ma sono
da solo eh aspetta Dove sei Io il mio
personaggio
è qualcosa di strano giustamente ce l'ho
diviso in delle celle non siamo nella
stessa cella possiamo vedere la stessa
cella Ma come Io volevo essere in
prigione con te era un po' qualcosa qua
il mio sconosciuto Che bello finalmente
posso essere impicciare da solo senza la
vita
oh Dai dimmi qual è la mia agenda Magari
possiamo incontrarci ho trovato un'altra
cella Quindi hai ragione forse possiamo
andare nelle varie Celle Ok allora io
provo a scappare No non dal gabinetto
provo a salire qua Ok magari ci
incontriamo qui nel nel condotto dai
reazione può essere Sì io qua c'è un
compagno di Cella che non si muove ha
deciso di rimanere in prigione per
sempre
[Musica]
Ecco Quindi da qua potevamo fare una
brava Bianca
Eccomi qua
Ok guarda
Ecco la guardia
Eccola qua vuole sicuramente Oh ma tu
devi portarci in cella eh Mi sa che ci
ha visto Anita
[Musica]
provo andare qua senza no bisogna fare
secondo piano dai piedi vieni vieni
vieni vieni vieni vieni aiuto aiuto
aiuto aiuto aiuto aiuto aiuto aiuto
aiuto aiuto aiuto aiuto aiuto Non è così
difficile
no mi ha preso ha preso le manette ti ho
arrestato no mi ha tipo fatto a pezzi
Tu sei già laggiù certo Dai sbrigati
Rita devi salire qui sali su queste
scale aiuto
Ok ce l'ho fatta si è fermato qua Hahaha
è un po' tonta non si accorge che io
sono qua bacia con il mocciolo
Ok dai andiamo ad esplorare il secondo
piano invece Dunque qua si può aprire No
non si apre Niente dobbiamo liberare le
altre persone
sono già scappati Oh no io sono caduto
attento Ciao ciao
in questa trappola no scappa Vittoria
scappa con le tue gambette
e eravamo troppo distratti Ok allora ho
capito bisogna stare super attenti a
questi buchi che ci sono qui nel secondo
piano e questo era il mio compagno di
Cella finalmente uscito dalla Sella
anche lui ma vedo che è rimasto lì
bloccato a correre sul posto
ma non si muove
così attenta Attenta qui c'è il buco
Cerchiamo di non cadere Ok
un altro attento lo vedo e ora via
andiamo
per fortuna che che è successo non
capivo dove stava andando per fortuna
che qualcuno ci ha aperti questo ci ha
aperto questo passaggio adesso dove
stiamo Secondo me è una trappola Anita
deve venire di qua non mi dire che sei
scesa No no anche se sono curioso di
vedere ci sono le ventole ah ah aiuto
quindi dobbiamo scendere no ci sono
delle ventole che ci fanno cadere
bisogna stare sopra attenti ad andare
avanti avanti avanti avanti avanti
avanti no Beh l'importante è che non ci
siamo sfracellati almeno Oddio Qua c'è
qualcuno sfracellato che cos'è questo no
è difficilissimo passare dall'altra
parte Uffa Ma come si fa
Ok ho capito Devi farti No devi saltare
Attento a non cadere ma io son caduto
Comunque OK riproviamo salta salta salta
salta dunque non si può Ah si può andare
di qua brava la vita no son caduto ho
una brutta notizia per te che cosa qua
c'è il moccio della Guardia
quello scaccolone di guardia l'ha
Spalmato qua Che schifo ragazzi non
riesco a capire chi ha detto che devi
saltare non vedo la strada Sei una
schiappa potrebbe anche essere così
impattata sto riuscendo ad andare avanti
no no Sono caduto Sono caduto perché sei
andato a destra dovevi andare tutto
dritto Adesso ci riprovo ci riproviamo
tutta vediamo vediamo vediamo
tutti quanto è schiappa Vitale da 1 a 10
probabilmente ci impiegherò un
pochettino Eh però ci voglio riprovare
vediamo il mio compagno di Cella se ci
riesce ma come c'è riuscito pure lui che
non riesce neanche a correre dai ci devi
riuscire anche tu vai Vai via Via No no
no all'ultimo passato ce l'avevi quasi
fresco Dov'è questo passaggio questo
gradino perché mi fa andare avanti
l'Italia Mettiti gli occhiali
Vediamo se questa volta ce la farà
lasciate un mi piace per fare in modo
che Vitale super in questo stage
finalmente
lasciate qualcosa di dietro
non c'è speranza lasciate un mi piace
così ci portate fortuna Adesso dove devo
andare che non riesco a capirlo
scelgo io come ho fatto a passare senza
accorgermene ora possiamo continuare qua
dentro della Guardia No queste sono le
fogne sta veramente non cadere nella
fogna Che schifo Ah che bello vedi solo
le fogne che che stanno facendo tutti i
loro vapori a forma di bolla credo che
dobbiamo andare qua dice di cliccare
questa leva non so cosa è cambiato è
apparso un passaggio sotto
mmm ah bisogna salire così Che figo sono
in testa Ehi aspetta sono qui Io sono in
testa adesso Ehi aspetta prendi un
dritto per aumentare la velocità
Mmm la super velocità non vedo l'ora
davvero
trasparente questo
drink Vabbè super velocità Uh Quanto mi
piace sono velocissima nessuno mi può
fermare neanche a caso per velocità eh
vitala
E comunque voglio dirti che sono in
vantaggio
tanto adesso cadi Non lo so sei tu
quella che cade con la super velocità in
genere strano che l'Italia non è ancora
caduto
sono troppo velocissimo Ehi Ma quanto
dura questo stage adesso scopriamo che
stiamo andando intorno
è la super velocità è un bel croccante
Oh mi sono registrato sei andato tu Eh
vai avanti e vi piacciono le mie nuove
orecchie bianche gatto bianco
non si vedono Eccole qua le mie orecchie
bianche
dove siamo Ah qua è dove dove i
carcerati parlano con con i familiari
Vedi Dici di rompere il vetro Come
rompere il vetro Vediamo se funziona
Sì tu devi rompere il tuo vetro Non puoi
rubare il microfono Esatto
Ok fatto Non mi dire che stiamo uscendo
adesso lo guardi lo guardi lo guardiamo
lì dietro di te continua
chiave blu Questa sarà la chiave per
arrivare alla prigione e dove dobbiamo
andare per evadere dalla prigione
Vai Ce la pensavi la guardia Ok andiamo
alla ricerca della porta blu con la
chiave gigante libreria Allora nella
libreria ci vuole la chiave Rosa quindi
dobbiamo prendere più
un casino
è difficilissimo io provo No per la
libreria ci vuole la chiave Viola io con
la chiave blu che cosa posso aprire Ma
io sono tornata indietro e ho preso la
chiave blu di nuovo e io sto Eccoti Ma
perché Ah no c'hai una chiave invisibile
Allora
non c'è niente nella tua mano vedo che
non c'è niente No no guarda guarda
guarda dietro di me ma perché vado
sempre dalla stessa porta Ok tu
distraila così io prendo le chiavi
proviamo ad andare in questi corridoi
centrale
mettiamo di trovare No coloriamo qua non
c'è nessuna chiave e se la chiave blu
funzionasse qua non funziona
aiuto aiuto aiuto
sono riuscito a passare non ci credo la
guardia è scomparsa all'improvviso e io
invece ho trovato un passaggio segreto
figo troppo ingegnoso questo passaggio
di Segreto dietro la libreria bellissimo
come possiamo fare ad andare lì Qua c'è
un tunnel ti porterà all'uscita della
prigione di questi prigionieri Guarda
che hanno fatto hanno messo per
addirittura l'impianto elettrico qui
e insomma non sono stati poi così tanto
bravi Guarda cosa è successo
farci niente Ah ci sono delle accette
qui pronte ad aspettarci Ok via
Vitale con le sue gambette sgambette
attraverso No è riuscito a passare senza
essere affettato neanche una volta che
peccato
Ecco un'altra guarda secondo me dobbiamo
passare qui a cercare di prendere questa
ah ah poverino È stato affettato non ci
posso crederci Guarda dai Provo io
attenta Non essere affettata aiuto che
dobbiamo passare Comunque entrambi ok Ho
abbassato la leva e adesso no
dobbiamo aprire tutte queste leve due
leve e forse anche tre belli questi due
c'è scritto tipo un castello questa
prigione Come facciamo a passare qui
attraverso queste bolle di fuoco e forse
c'è un'altra leva che dobbiamo premere
ehm non lo so proviamo a passare lo
stesso Ciao
Forse dobbiamo richiudere quelle leve Ma
no come no forse c'è un'altra leva che
dobbiamo premere non abbiamo pronto
Ah giusto quindi dobbiamo trovare il
cancello Forse è qui se il cancello
fosse qui vediamo dobbiamo esplorare
meglio
come facciamo a passare qua allora ci
deve essere per forza Un segreto Un
colpo così ce l'ho fatta
e Invece avevo ragione ho visto già l'ho
salutare da qua Ah ok mi sbruciacchiato
mi ha bruciacchiato le gambine Così
impari
[Risate]
[Musica]
Ciao nelle punte del Castello che in
realtà è una prigione Ma si è
trasformata nelle segrete di un castello
Boh ogni tanto guarda guarda
quella cosa lì
adesso ti raggiungo anzi
sei stato sfracellato o sbaglio ma
sbaglio hai due magliette una blu e una
gialla così ma che fa freddo
si vedeva la chiesa gialla Attenzione
qui ci sono gli spuntoni
passato
Ok devo stare attenta aspettiamo
Vieni indietro
bisogna salire su da questa fune Guarda
Oh Che figo tanto lo prenderò privato
sfracellato ora sono io in vantaggio in
questo ponte Infatti
sbrighiamoci Oh no c'è di nuovo la
guardia così è riuscito a passare tutto
il ponte Certo che sei così avanti
così una freccia Quindi immagino che
dovrò andare qua io seguo
Prima
guarda guarda l'ha preso anche a me
neppure arrestato
quindi dobbiamo tornare lì c'è un'altra
leva ma perché e poi sì Io sto scappando
nello ascensore quest'anno
non avevano premuta Dov'è l'altra leva
Oddio Ma sei sicura che sono due leve Sì
sono due leve Oh Anna son tornare
nell'ascensore ma ce la guardia qua eh
eh Non puoi farmi niente qua ciao ciao
ciao ciao
mi hai fatto passare davanti alla
Guardia senza che ti facesse niente
perché la guardia sta cercando di
prendere Beh la guardia È distratta dal
cibo visto che si apre questa porta
Aprite la porta Ah sei riuscito a
scappare Sì ci sono i laser qui
evviva dai Anita Cerca Odio Cerca di non
farti affettare
Oh no altri laser la muffa però
credo che siamo vicini all'uscita sono
troppo velocissimo Guarda qui c'è
proprio il buco scatola e la roccia con
le mattonelle no Vitale
No ma io pensavo che questo tubo
portasse fuori questo scavo portasse
fuori nel mozzo della Guardia Che schifo
favola il ritiro ok dice di prendere
questa tavola tavola goccia eh cavolo al
ritiro e cavolo la goccia No sono caduta
nel pozzo che schifo
tanto sapete che noi abbiamo un
trucchetto cioè riutilizzare sempre la
stessa tavola tu non tornare indietro a
prenderla Ok allora la riprendo Ah ce
n'è un'altra più bella oh caduto ha
fatto cadere la tavola ho caduto la
tavola
devi tornare indietro anzi ti devi
buttare nel Moccia No no
ti piacciono non fa peccato Volevo
vederti nuotare nel moccio della Guardia
credo che siamo vicini all'uscita e io
sono in vantaggio
la sfida finale con la Guardia
non capisco Stiamo lanciando le uova la
guardia uova Ma perché Cosa c'entra Oh
no che lui ci stava lanciando i mattoni
che
mattoniere aiuto
che sta facendo ha distrutto tipo una
parte del pavimento
aiuto
beccati questa frittata
Dai manca poco manca poco c'è lui spara
stia con il mitragliatore sia per
rompere il pavimento e poi fa anche le
capriole 5 Ma perché in queste sei
promosso ogni tanto non mettono qualcosa
che noi possiamo controllare quei robot
Sarebbe fichissimo per noi avessimo quei
robot invece che loro comunque dov'era
la vita ti voglio tirare un nuovo in
testa
no mi hai eliminato
Ciao Rita Oh beccati
adesso ti importi Che cosa hai fatto
Rita mi ha fatto Volare di nuovo Ehi gli
manca pochissimo di vita ce l'ho quasi
fatta perché tu sei morto sono qui
veramente sei trasformato
Beccati questo poliziotto così
vai colpiscilo sopra
dai brava Ah brava così ne manca poco
ancora uno colpisce meglio vedi che non
gli fanno niente uh uh devi colpire dove
c'è il distintivo quello giallo ok L'hai
colpito pronti
Vitale sfracellata Ma come vieni qua
Seguimi si è aperto il cancello via non
ti vedo Dai vieni qua Allora qui c'è
Dov'è il Belgio Dov'è il Belgio
devo metterci subito Qui c'è una torre
di Napoli
è tutto è tutta protetta Ma perché il
gioco è diventato in prima persona ha
detto non riesco Non riesco a saltare
forse non è questa l'uscita forse
un'altra uscita credo che sia questa
dove sta andando Non ci credo non avevo
capito nulla Anita aveva capito
l'abbiamo detto non sapevo dove andare
Hai guardato qua per capire dove andare
posso solo caduta ah ah togliete questa
prima persona che non si capisce niente
pure io sono caduto devo prendere quel
mezzo Ehi Togliti qua non ci credo che
sei così avanti dai Katia Anita Prova a
cadere
sì No no hai preso ah
che cosa ti aiuta
l'ho preso anch'io adesso ma non salta
tanto in alto Ok allora forse devi
premere giù giù aumenta affatto certo
Ora vi lasciamo Qua quattro caselline su
cui cliccare per vedere i nostri altri
video cliccando quello che preferite Eh
devi mangiare tutti Ciao